you
okay I am back to be live in a while
since i've streamed on me chess it was
like at least a week maybe more
actually I screamed I streamed about a
week ago in in st. Louis I had like
pterygium this on stream three or four
genes and audio was terrible and I
apologize to anyone who watched that
stream it was a fun stream though it was
just the microphone settings were off
but I'm back home now
the beach has title arena starts in
about 15 minutes
and magnus carlsen is playing not only
in the title of arena but he's playing
right now which I'm just following him
he opened the chat I see one commenter
Adria Senseo they drove Ascencio below
yeah I think this is a typical ritual
for Carlson - first of all play that
titled arena every month and then like
an hour before the title arena he warms
up against some strong GM though I
actually have I was supposed to have a
pending challenge against him but maybe
I don't let me send Carlsen the
challenge maybe he'll accept a profit
that will challenge him - one minute
just leave it open there and I'll go
back to to watching his games
addictions on Magnus defending the title
I mean last time I give Magnus like over
90% chance and he barely won and you're
tang was on the verge of winning and
somehow Magnus staged like an epic
comeback uh winning maybe the last 20
games in a row
though it was pretty cool um this time I
mean I still have two favorite Magnus
over everyone else if we go let's just
open a new tab and see the field of
players it's just a regular as Andrew
tang what's this guy's name bortnik
Alexander bortnik I think it's gonna be
a match or kind of a race between
Magnuson and Andrew I still favorite
Magnus at probably 75 the 80% to win but
you never know surprises could happen I
think last time he maybe wasn't taking
it as seriously he was streaming the
event at this time I don't know this
time we'll see what happens
I should also know I was doing
commentary last time I wasn't actually
playing the event so I was following
Angie's games and Magnus's games pretty
closely this time I'll play the event
and I'll try and make some kind of I
want to say I'll make some kind of run
but I'll try and play decent chess
maybe I'll break twenty-five or
twenty-six hundred but we'll see it's a
tough event
there's many strong players hello to
more people in the chats uh wan-koo G
Don John 1:3 for first time here welcome
thanks for being here
yeah the the excitement won't start for
another about like forty to fifty
minutes but ok it's always exciting
watching watching Magnus play
he was drinking a bunch last time yeah I
think Magnus was promoting Corona last
time on his stream maybe not necessarily
a bad thing
shoutout to z nation chess good to see
you the chess boy Jeff I'm I said your
name correctly the first time
I think I'm gonna play a few games just
to warm up I got a new laptop and I've
been trying to play with the trackpad
but the trackpad just has a different
feel and I can't play I can't play
quickly with it so I've switched to
using my my $50 gaming mouse I don't
know if people can see this a logitech
whatever it has so many buttons and so
much functionality which I haven't yet
explored but I was goofing around with
the settings and I'm trying to get used
to it not used to playing with a mouse
so it's gonna feel weird hello to you
Savage I'm doing pretty well just trying
to get back into chest mode so
let's watch one more madness game and
see how bed inspired by his play
well did white just hang a queen now
there's 96 so it's interesting
wait Agnes is in trouble mate is
happening on that seven
what's the material counts as Magnus
just upper rook
back is upper rook
yeah [ __ ] black as everything defended
- why does a bunch of pawns butt
okay queen d8 Rock a tricky
as long as black can trade Queens or
just simplify
this game is about over once this game
ends I'm going to start the game
hello two gone man feel like there's a
bunch of new people in the chats hello
to all the new people good to see you
all I will say there's gonna be a lot of
people streaming today once the
tournament starts I think last time
there were like 15 to 20 players
streaming and all title players pretty
good turnout
actually be mating somehow in c3 or just
take pawns Brooke c7 my smooth
hmm okay now from Compaq is up to minor
pieces white is still pushing pawns
not so easy
p8 Oh
as Magnus gonna lose us Magnus is gonna
lose us he was up a full rook and he was
up like two minor pieces he pushing
oh my gosh Magnus flagged
that happen we get a slow-motion replay
what
you can never like just assume you'll
win in a bullet game when you're up so
much material
how did that happen like he was mating
he was offer a full rook
I guess it's easier to push pawns like
whites main goal was pushing pawns
blacks goal is to mate which wasn't so
simple
or already some some issues
come on I mean
five bucks should just go after the king
ninety-five
okay I'm not one to criticize Magnus's
play but that was pretty uh pretty sad
let's go and play some bullets if anyone
wants to challenge me feel free good to
see you excise sparks shout out to our
ex um big shout out to our ex making
this whole Lee chest thing happen
Oh excise sparks just subbed I think
thank you excise sparks appreciate that
I know I haven't I haven't streamed in a
while on me chest so if my sub count has
been going down but I am planning wait
oh that's uh I thought that was a
challenge from Magnus but that's my
pending challenge to Magnus okay I'll
play the sky one game I'm just trying to
move my mouse quickly not
not now slipped too much what is this
let's transpose into some classical
names Oh
oh this is a casual game
it's okay I guess the h6 in the fourth
be with you yet today is May fourth
which means tomorrow is Cinco DeMayo
it's exciting
I almost pooped when
about to play Magnus yeah I've actually
never played Magnus in a chess game
um at least that I know of we played in
soccer and basketball for a few days in
st. Louis that was a couple of years ago
very good soccer player and basketball
player just good all-around athlete this
guy just hang up on her Queen
I was generous with him I'm getting more
challenges I'll play I'll play father
miss prime I think thalamus prime has
been challenging wait
I keep seeing dr. drunken steam okay I'm
gonna play this guy cuz he's he's been
wanting to play me a lot over the last
week I've just been too busy so here's
your game I'll play a London I meant to
play h4 there but it's okay
like at four I like these close
positions because they're so easy to
play in bullets ooh I didn't mean to
close it up that much though what is
going on
I'm gonna bring a night to see five
he's going to bring a night to see for
I'll take it and we have some position a
for repeat one I'll play on the
queenside I have to bring my Bishop back
probably one
oh it's double up maybe and go for b5
pushes maybe improve the King first
there's no rush
like White has so much time maybe dance
around for a little bit now he's
attacking my knight I'll play 96 and
then probably put my queen on a three
that's possible or even better put my
bishop on a three it's like a maze
Oh Oh he attacks my night and I didn't
see it but now I get the B file that's
good Brooke b7 happens and he just had a
queen that's nice
let's invade with other rook is this a
move that's a move right
so tricky and then let's do this you
control over the B file somehow my
bishop will someday come in maybe to e5
let's not draw arrows to take more free
pieces between b7 maybe when the d5 pawn
when a5 on
li e 5 and then meet him somehow
okay that was fun I'm singer is back
good to see you
and his favorite iron I guess that's
because crew 64 is not in I am yet oh
thank you for the kind words yeah I'm
getting used to playing with this mouse
I was playing around with all these like
mouse settings I have no idea what these
numbers mean but I just kept fiddling
with them until something works
yeah to answer JCS the arena starts in
about 39 minutes so I'm just warming up
I have so many pending challenges let's
play this guy maybe is also playing in
the title arena another title player is
he online he's online okay
good luck have fun
I am not commentating on the titled
arena I am I'm playing I guess I am
playing and commentating just on my own
stream but I'm not doing the official
commentary chess explained is doing the
official commentary
um and I don't know if Magnus will
stream because he's streamed last time
and it was exciting
thousands of people were watching him oh
if he streams again that'll be uh will
be again very exciting x-eye sparks with
the hundred bits thank you thank you
excise sparks being very generous today
I don't like my position it was awkward
at four
I'm just low on space maybe five at some
points
and then go for the capture
[Music]
let's play this preventing Bishop III
and then I'll go for a c4 and maybe I
can use something maybe Queen f2 no
Queen f2 is that that's checkmate 9h to
his mates how did that happen
oh wow I was nice
um okay maybe I can break 2500 before
the tournament starts
you should have started two minutes
earlier I would have hosted you you can
still host me if you're not streaming if
you are streaming then I guess you can't
host me oh maybe you mean rated there's
a difference between rating and hosting
I think very similar but okay let's play
this guy again I have to get used to
playing the London do the and routine
pre move
okay unguent opening will play this move
order this is a also viable move order
where black can't play Bishop f5
and then e4 I think is strong
this is some like theoretical line I
think actually not sure if I was
supposed to take on c-44 there but this
looks decent the ship can develop
maybe f3 at some point
if he plays Bishop g7 or probably
tickets
when defy that's a blunder
it's a donation Niels went thank you for
the $5 thanks for the game still a
little sad about the Queen blender um
yeah I mean
that's a natural feeling after
blundering a queen it's that's how you
learn
um okay this is a nice position
[Music]
I think all oh oh ms:i move in d2 this
is still a nice position maybe a Castle
queenside somebody file action
is this
I do something fancy
so going to be calm
maybe 96 coming
yeah I'm not meeting him but I should be
flagging him at some point
a Brooks
maybe p4 in Bishop c5
ooh a a Bishop c5 where is the mate
boo Bishop F sevens mate that's nice
um okay I'm not keeping up with the
chats main-sequence twelve I don't want
to pay my raid target what does that
mean
now even understand most of those words
actually I don't what's our raid targets
vixie FPS is so smooth yeah I don't I
didn't realise I'm streaming at 60fps
but I guess I am
what's up on Achatz thanks for watching
again a wrap Coen seed yeah I am warming
up that's that's the point of this I'm
trying to get used to my new mouse which
isn't exactly new I've had it for over a
month
I just haven't used it yet
I'm singer has to go
I'm back after Ireland's
Wow are you on a plane well have a safe
flight
yeah smooth travels
can you play the Alekhine if I'm black
I'll pre move Knight f6 and I'll see
what happens
Oh so I'm singer hosted someone else
t-that happens okay uh pending
challenges
I'll place this guy I'll fly a 1200
maybe not the best preparation for the
title arena just giving him a game is
provisional he could have had just bad
luck yeah he should be beatable let's
play play some aggressive chess
ah he plays prophylactically okay
remove some moves remove that
wait Magnus challenged me no it's a
pending challenge it says waiting so
to myself earlier I thought he was
challenging me but I'm just challenging
him he won't accept
best shot at playing him is somehow
getting paired against him in the title
arena but we'll see how that goes in the
pre movie sixer
maybe Queen d5 aggressive move offending
and attacking
now I'm threatening me it's maybe he'll
miss it
take a game
uh no keep up
I'm gonna play the highest rated player
first helipad sir good luck
in sequence I notice the st. Louis chess
club all of us oh wow
wait what
although host:you but they don't have
auto host enabled
as a possible man
that's just confusing I have no idea who
manages their twitch account
I know they're more focused on YouTube
but yeah I don't know I don't know if
anyone is intentionally trolling you or
maybe they are I don't know
um can I take on f7 95-96 maybe not
let's switch let's play my GFI right
away I think he has to play d5
I'm winning at least upon
yeah this looks fun
see those notifications
guess they can't
Asians are kind of annoying they they
pop up like above the window
I'm trying to calculate night take T
five queen h5 probably doesn't work
cause Bishop g5 o Bishop to g5 is
actually annoying let's take on that
seven and I'm looking for some sort of
mating ideas okay each hex not a big
deal
I don't think you will be brave enough
to take the night's
even if he is be flagging
hmm
you
for luck
is that really the first-place prize
wait what's Idol arena
the first-place prize is three Heusen
dollars well Magnus is gonna win it and
then we chest will only have to give out
$600 the Magnus Sigma never accepts his
his first-place prize
Oh Tushar streamed on me chest for the
first time that's cool
hey you got listed as a streamer yeah
for those of you who don't know anyone
can stream on me chess and be listed as
a streamer you just go to like watch in
streamers and then you see all the
streamers I shouldn't
and be promoting these other people but
you see who's live and then you just
create your streaming profile link your
twitch accounts pretty straightforward
I've ten pending challenges so many
people want to play me ro dream
either highest-rated will play her
Cara's dream
okay let's say another London
I'll be be my main opening for the day
but if anyone has opening
recommendations let me know
maybe I'll get inspired by people
probably not but we'll see
we need sevens always a tricky move it
enables a five
but this is okay
the Castle queenside
ooh he castles queenside
okay I'll do the same
Icelandic candidate what does that is
that Scandinavian where you do like
85 9 of 6 you could play that
pleasant position
- eventful
very positional game rook age six I
think is a very powerful move ooh
94 was a very powerful move
hmm maybe I win the pawn back like
Bishop t3
and then the spawns week he could play
King c7
or he could it mean ultimate pawns of
these pawns are hanging and now this
pawns hanging winning all his pawns now
maybe mating him
actually it's not so easy to meet
it's easy to flag let's see
[Music]
this resigns that slice
good game yeah I
as if Magnus is plain Magnus is playing
he always plays his user name is dr.
drunken Steen the title Vorenus now
starts in 27 minutes
nerble nerble Chernobyl let's have a
hard time pronouncing that I want Magnus
to give a prize pack until it's like a
hundred K first place that would be
hilarious
um okay I still have 10 pending
challenges I'll just go in order here
I'm the know keep up good luck
well pre-move night s6 as i would play
the alkyne earlier
oh he plays d4 he's playing a London
do the stuff
have been bad if he took on c5 but okay
this is okay should f5 I think is a move
either view move 94 is a move
already nice position his queen is it if
he
or ig5
let's just develop
I play Bishop d3
no because he has my si - can I take
here not going to calculate I'm just
going to do it looks fun
probably just loses a piece but oh my
gosh Queen b5 check he didn't see it
there's some compensation now there's
definitely compensation the fizz King
Gandhi one
paid
at the C file
and it makes
these signai dishes
okay
I like the elephant gambit what is
elephant cabinets
what did Rx just do
up
so confused
our X used ad permitted
yes I'll allow this
to lish ulis I was watching my youtube
video that I posted I think it was
posted today
it's very hard to keep up with which and
YouTube or I've been doing recently is
I've been putting like archived twist
streams on YouTube and then been
scheduling them so yesterday I scheduled
maybe like five days in a row of a
previous twitch streams every day at
like 10 a.m. my time there will be a new
video uploaded at some point I am going
to try to transition to YouTube content
like more exclusive YouTube content be a
bit more instructive and answer people's
questions but for now now I feel like
twitch is the best way to build build a
good audience
um
okay oh I just play no keep up and now
he's in the chats good game no keep up
it is weird cuz there's a delay that's
the nature of twitch it's probably good
for me that when you play me you're not
hearing my wheel real-time thoughts
Russia if it's bullets then you can go
called snipe maybe slightly annoying
aku's is asking what you like you try
playing my losing BOTS
ah maybe later who's your losing bot
Lila chess is on I was trying to
challenge Li chess earlier but he wasn't
accepting challenges maybe there's some
updates happening oh and thank you
drag dragna - for the follow i still
have ten pending challenges I'm just
gonna quickly have stream labs open - so
I can see who's following Thank You
Berlin Jed axe
preciate the follow um it was our bit
discombobulated but now they're back
okay so I'm just logging into stream
labs I'll accept another challenge very
soon yeah I'm sorry to all the title
players who can't
who can't play the Tucker what did I say
I'm sorry for all the non title players
who can't play the titled arena so this
is uh I guess your dose of just for the
day
I'm not playing mo two men I assume this
is a mo to man from twitch as well
pretty the loyal viewer very active on
twitch I'll play he's alive he is alive
let's play an alkyne
I forget who suggested it but someone
was suggesting that kind earlier
and it's a strange opening like white
get some space advantage but it's
actually somewhat straightforward to
play like you just develop as black but
the bishop on g4 and then these pawns
are target's rush ad for woo he does
that move I can take it play my t4 and
then he has three things hanging
I'm winning something
winning a lot of things he plays queen
g2 I would be ideal hey he played Queen
d2 haha
that's so funny yeah Alekhine success
now I just want to open files in the
center
but it might be hard to open files when
I just have pawns okay now at least the
D file is open
the chancel ie4
putting more things
egg game
two men what country is he from Saudi
Arabia that's cool
the world was that the world rappin in
blitz championships were in Saudi Arabia
I've never been to that country but it
would be cool to go someday yeah thanks
for the game whoo - man wrote you man
double-oh-seven
I knew that the name was slightly
different old tide is saying playing
sixteen hundred's
my first pairing will not be Magnus the
pairings work the sense we're like
number one seed plays number two seed
but if I get to play Magnus I'll have to
like start off well and then then
hopefully got lucky
something a hello.tex villager thanks
for watching thank you for the cheer
doorbell doorbell appreciate the one bit
yeah it is hard to keep up with a chat
I'm doing my best
maybe I need more mods ex villager is a
mod let's ma da x I sparks long overdue
wait what's X I sparks
ah
you
that's okay
else I can trust
I should not main-sequence
odd pains
okay shout out to main-sequence
I actually met main-sequence in person
several months ago I was in Australia we
played we didn't play the exact same
tournament but we played like same event
at separate sections Thank You boss turn
off for the follow accept another
challenge here trying to see if I
recognize any of these names if not I'm
just gonna go in order alright like a
grandmaster good luck
the tournament starts in 19 minutes
at some point I need a water break or a
tea break
we'll see
here we have a tomorrow's
was it that commented on Twitter it may
have been ex villager I posted the photo
of to untwist me playing chess like you
can barely see the chess board but I'm
pretty sure it was ax villager who
commented something like I see a time on
of classic rosin or something like that
it is one of my favorite openings very
very straightforward to play I've been
playing it for maybe about mmm 5 to 10
years I don't lose track
huge time advantage he's gonna take on
e5 and then oh no he's not my queen is
slightly over it works castle a3 is not
a great move because II for will open
the B file
whoa okay
that's somewhat self-destructive
is now there's going to be is on the sea
oil
what to do should take off too
upon this Queens over alerts
this take take take that doesn't work
but back
id3 threats now night see for threats in
addition to both rooks hanging
okay as a nice game
um her name was Vanessa yeah time versus
Vanessa
Oh Patrick JMT is here we played on me
chess really that's cool I'm an alt
account feel free to send me the game um
I might remember it it was alla bullet
game
okay let's move on
time for a few more games I'll play
Tushar aka Anna cuts let's play efore
sit up a little bit
um
oh it's gone now
play some I'm going to play it like the
Grand Prix set up but it's against a
five-o
what happens here
it was queen
Tristan my t5 looks nice maybe see three
preventing 94
yeah I don't mind this position nice
position
it's Center good development not going
to trade pieces this because White has
more space
definitely not trading I'll put the coin
on h3 and then go for a 5 or I can just
sack on each six probably don't need to
calculate Thank You Mitch bark for the
follow
five coming the best move is probably
Knight g4 Thank You Joel rocky for the
follow
very appreciative of all the follows
today AC is greater than MC
a King crusher greater than magnus
carlsen doesn't make any sense
um yeah to reiterate I am playing with
an actual mouse I showed it on cam a few
minutes ago here it is again by Logitech
Gaming Mouse it lights up for no
apparent reason
but getting used to it it's feeling
better and better
I will admit I hold the mouse very
strangely I've done videos for the st.
Louis chess club where like the the
video shows how I hold the mouse and the
meanest comments like yet are about how
I hold the mouse cuz I click with my
thumb rather than my mind
um okay I have more pending challenges
who's the lowest rated player who's
challenging me
I keep thinking Magnus is challenging me
but it's so disappointing
let's play this guy I can't pronounce
this name but I'm pretty sure this is ex
villager from Norway well I wonder have
you ever met Magnus Carlsen
we're from Norway
good luck have fun let's play another
alkyne a main-sequence just subbed Thank
You main-sequence
at the sub either way there's a new
emote there is a there's a Fabiano
Caruana emotes which I don't think I'd
publicize too much
um but also I don't know if I've
announced this like to publicly yet but
I became a twitch partner a few weeks
ago which gives me access to allow more
uh more emotes so if people have email
suggestions let me know I have like a
whole like stash of photos of top
players the Fabiano emote I actually
took that picture I don't know if too
many people know this but Cruz 64 has an
emote of Kasparov which I actually made
for him and I took the cos fara picture
too
so I'm thinking about making like a Sam
Shanklin emote and an Aussie pic this
cuz they're the best champions now
but I'm open to suggestions
just wanna push my econ I show the D
file wait this is blitz
oh he tricked me I thought those this is
one minute why I was planting so fast
oh man okay I have time to think but I'm
not going to think
I'm just going to try and flag him
there's okay there's no there's no
increment and it's casual that's good
this what I need
what to do f5 I want I still want to
open the D file I take he takes with
pawn
let's play Knight a5 ideas of Knight c4
maybe also see 5c for their kind of
conflicting plans but hopefully one of
them good workout
maybe I'll so like c5 and then take and
then this
there's so much pressure
you
I have six
you
and then this these two things are
attacked
see one and then I can probably take and
then play E 4 and then C 5
and early defendi for thank you more
qiyam for the follow
lots of new faultless today very
appreciative I just hung a knight but he
didn't realize it I really hang a knight
there on the night
and sitting sacrificing it let's just
play b5 though there's a trick if he
takes I can play rip t2 and thank you
ego mystical 1376 for the follow this
case I take on threatening d3
of time do I want to play d3 here
mmm mr. Thicke these pawns look pretty
menacing
remove rotate
for
for the flag
here
moving more stuff I'm just getting
warmed up for the the titled arena
doorbell thank you for the follow
nor Paul gave a bit earlier to
such a generous person
this ending might not be better for
black and it's equal material I'm losing
this pawn which is kind of sad maybe
he'll take with rook oh I don't even
have Bishop before now I'm down a pawn I
have to dirty Fagin Thank You Kartik
nine eight nine nine for the follow
let's play a five and then Bishop b4
whoo he hung his bishop
Oh generous
oh he didn't hang his bishop not seeing
tactics
I saw the tactic I just didn't see the
defense and now I can play Bishop before
now I went as bishop that's my
okay I won I'm on a winning streak
um I don't think I've lost a game
recently go kill think thank you for the
follow I wonder if he's related to no
joke
another streamer and me chest moderator
thank you Peter is zero nine three nine
two for the follow only people following
I want to take a break but I want to
play more chess
um
who's the lowest rated player who's
challenging me in one minute hey let's
play uh the sky
I don't know if the peas are silent to
suffer
a pair whatever your name is good luck
let's play another Alec I'm I'm kind of
falling in love with this opening it's
just so easy to play play like bring the
Knights of b6 v g6 and g7 another follow
from Tess can 1963 appreciate that
okay I'm going for the gold alekhine
stuff this guy didn't put the pawn and
see for it okay you just hung up on at
me five
Thank You Gert Jaka for the follow okay
I'm up upon Russ F pawn forward
the bishop
oh he wants to trade Bishop's
I have to allow that
of big'o Don flaw thanks for the follow
I have a lot of ponds in the center
pushing pawns as long as I can
I want to do this and this and this
maybe this
I've realized it's so much easier to
draw arrows with a mouse because I don't
have to worry about like this
right-click thing on the trackpad it's
like a specific button for like clicking
on the mouse
984 okay let's get the B file I still
want to push pawns but he's kind of
setting up a blockade alko licks thanks
for the follow
now I want to play d4
um nc5
great pollen structure I'm okay sacking
the change
for interesting
no eyes Mouse lips oh my gosh I'm losing
against this guy he's 1,200
ah
became not the best ending Thank You
core Chester for the follow and ewj wing
for the follow Wang er Wang I never know
maybe Wang
the tournament starts very soon I'm
getting more challenges
I do kind of have to take a break
let's take a small break his madness
stop playing is not playing okay
another follow from prep Cohen seed
thank you
um I just realize I have not had the
chat open for a while
uh hello Tori boodle hello pure frozen
fire lots of people in the chat is crawl
this crawl is asking how come no
background music no background music
because I don't want to get muted for
like copywriting and also if you want to
listen to music you can listen to your
own music and have the stream running I
think that's a better experience for
everyone is if I choose music someone's
gonna hate it I hope that's okay with
people let's let's move on
Oh excise Marx is asking can you maybe
do analysis of Alekhine opening just
with strategic ideas um yeah I don't
think I'll have too much time for that
but maybe I can
I had an idea the other day for just a
new type of stream where I just answered
opening questions or I just spent time
going over openings that people want to
learn so maybe I'll start and create a
study for this and just have it
open for the future let's make a new
study
what do i call this look
answering opening wait I already have a
study for answering opening questions
eight minutes
and study
Turing opening question
oh the title arena starts soon yeah let
me bookmark this bookmark
chess there we go and that way and
always come back to this maybe I can
just add a new chapter we can call it
Alekhine so maybe in the future I'll
remember
thank you pure frozen fire for the
follow efore 9 f6
and you think I can say quickly I mean
the idea of the Alekhine is it's a
counterpunching opening you're basically
provoking light to overextend and then
you try and you try and target like
center so a lot of the times white will
have some setup like this where it
visually it looks very appealing for
light because there's there's so much
space early on but the idea for black is
to a counter punch just like play d6
right c6 there's a few ways to develop
this bishop you could sometimes play e6
or the plans that I've been choosing are
g6 and Bishop g7 and if White's not an
experienced player it's very often that
they'll get in trouble with one of these
bonds like for example in I have three
Bishop g4 there's already some ideas of
targeting the D or pawn on take on take
e5 is already a threat
um
for fun let me show one funny Alekhine
trap that I ran into many years ago
against Alejandro Ramirez I was playing
a blitz tournament in Philly and Ali was
drinking a little bit
he made me think that he wasn't taking
the game too seriously and he's playing
some very strange moves
I played D for your he better take a
cure here
is a trap for black but I walked into
his flight
Alejandro play tonight to be for
he's playing like very rightward I don't
want to say flamboyantly he's playing
like you just didn't care about the game
naturally I just play a3 thinking the
night has to retreat and then to my
shock I mean take t4 happened why he was
just losing a pond that's amazing
because it's black though just a funny
chopin alkyne good blitz trap because
white smooths were very natural
I think Astra night before it's not so
easy for whites as bishop at fives of
threats
so it's a useful like a bit of opening
knowledge to have a lot of players I've
never seen this before I was like 2200
or 2300 at the time I I ran into this
line
anyway let's let's get ready for the
tournament ooh
Carlson might be streaming ha ha a lot
of people are streaming that's exciting
after watch his stream later
for now let's go to tournaments
and then we chest titled arena
ah
I'm not even in the top hundred I
thought my bullet rating was decent it's
not decent enough um yeah no hard
feelings if you want to watch some
Norwegian guy go for it but I do
appreciate people sticking with me we'll
try and make this fun I have one goal
for this tournament I one goal is to
play Carlsen let's see if that happens
hernán starts in about 21 seconds
okay excise sparks sticking with me
nice I will upload this to YouTube so if
you guys you want to watch some replay
in the future or even ten years from now
it should be on YouTube wait why oh I
have two close tabs okay
okay I'm gonna play one of these guys
ashen nation' 15 okay I don't know if my
warmup was exactly the best warm-up
because I was playing very weak players
and now I'm playing a very strong player
no offense to all the weak players who I
played
I'll put the night on f8 I'm going to
try and be solid and keep a timed
advantage wants to play before ok now he
has some iqp sort of
six was probably a bit too weakening
anding c6 now maybe put the nine on d5
and hold onto stuff
mmm this is actually really annoying
I'll do this move
want to simplify
upon uh - I do at 6:00 know maybe this
and then at 6:00
soon he's gonna play Bishop c4 at b3
or that even stronger ouch
a tick I can do this Bishop on d5 is
attacked
this is not a great start his lights
where's our week oh he mated me I was a
really bad start I mean 240 fifth place
I'll play Fiona we'll see what happens
games are finishing
boom fist okay let's try and recuperates
let's play a semi slot maybe Cambridge
Springs if he lets me well this Queen b3
play a6 and b5
mmm we still be five at some points
is okay because I get c5 in
just Castle okay let's try and treat
this a bit positionally rook c8 97 trade
off the bishops I want to get the bishop
hair looking pretty likely because I can
play this yes to take and the position
opens up I still have the bishop hair
before as a threat which he just missed
now I'm just going to be up a bunch of
pieces
okay I was a good comeback
you have any tips how to get raisins out
of the pot okay maybe someone in the
check and give you tips on that but hey
I'm in the top hundred with two points
okay Danny rod let's play London
mmm six move order spleef no Knight f3
and then II for if you take some b2 this
case I have my p3
opening nuances here Thank You Nathan
after the cheer
I like my position
lady for soon maybe I'll play like he
wants to do stuff
bring the nightie do first
g3 and f4 f5
maybe a four-night b-52 ditional idea
dominates all areas of the board
this is maybe kind of weak I'm so
tempted to play out five the dot his
dark squares are so weak
pawn sacrifice wasn't early justified
but we'll see
put the other rook on f1 and then go for
g4 someday
now a file Angie file or half-open Ryan
pressure the F file I have some some
nice gun happening 96 is coming I really
stopped who he's gonna play at 6 o or
not hey while I win that pawn I've night
there
and it's just a trade kind of 93
interesting move I'm up a lot of time
I don't know what's happening in the
position
um
donation MOTU man donated $1 thank you
it's likeif or move quickly
at the rook
you one probably
ooh this is bad this is really bad
b5 maybe ooh this is good this is really
good
B rook this is a test of my mouse oh
he's not even gonna try to flag me that
was nice
that was really dirty though thanks for
the $1 Muthu men almost distracted me
but not quite
yeah this is where it's kind of hard to
look at the chat and play but I am
trying my best
I apologize if I miss any follows or
cheers or nations or whatever okay I'm
on some streak I'm playing a slightly
weaker player who's still in I am by
this line
who he's playing some interesting theory
this is what MVL played a little bit
actually don't know any theory in this
line another 10 bits from Nathan thank
you
I think the night kind of trapped but
maybe not
it will take that
try and get some sort of reasonable
developments
it's I just read that comment saying
don't be distracted I know this has
happened before
but the query money to maybe the bishop
can be rerouted to be
there's so much pressure though they see
through me
okay well now I can castle safely it
doesn't check me on before
this is really annoying I'm losing a
pawn you can take on that three and take
there at least this office of color
bishop so I'm out that ton of time he's
moving way too slowly
reading b7 which he missed
maybe he saw sacrifice I like my bishop
on d5
this is nice
ooh scary though at the same time
ah this is very scary
Oh is bad
I hope you slow it's been slow
hey his rook got trapped I was
unexpected and he's gonna flag back to
tournament hey I'm top 20 it's not bad I
mean I I think I'm like one hundred and
fourth seed or something
I mean I'm within range of playing
Carlsen
that's my only goal like play Carlsen in
a chess game it's on my life bucket list
oh wait
I must be oh this guy's strong I have to
play London I hold my own and move
quickly
what happens
he's playing like Lila chess - Lee let's
play this evening take that ooh not a
good position already I have no idea
what's going on here
c6 is weak
you have to play rookie one soon does
that move h3
H to bring the rook in oh yeah I had
Bishop d6 maybe now I have knight c6 I'm
winning material
uh what do I want to do maybe queen bee
one
mmm and then this is trying to hold on
and not blunder
this is really scary and kind of losing
material though I lost a pawn but maybe
I went upon back
me I went map on
everywhere stop it with the Knights
you
I play f4 and try and win s7 oh he can't
move as a night because he gets oh he
did move his night the trade
okay
you
I'm shaking
no I'm losing this how am i losing this
ouch
position two
okay that was disappointing the goal is
not to be on tilts I'm still 31st place
at some sort of streak they're still not
used to the mouse with these time
scramble situations let's stick with my
time on of Sicilian it will have an
Alton
but eath be interesting I can take
for he played 83 he's no he knows what
he's doing
upon Angie six maybe like this move
first
ng6
I can take and play Queen d6
maybe nine of four at some point what
does that move oh he's gonna win a six
kind of scary
looks okay though
Rocio
lots of pins happening lots of x-ray
vision
maybe King h8 get the King off the
diagonal of the bishop so on the play
night ooh he was spending that a7 do
this preventing - Evan he's gonna play
Queen h4 and another six or that
difficult position
[Music]
I still want to play a 906
endings
or passive kind of necessary
okay 907 very soon
ah how's a good move
I play this oh that was terrible that
was so bad he takes he's just killing me
but maybe not
wait I'm still alive I'm just down upon
here oh what a good move by him he wins
what queen
ah so unfortunate
okay I'm still top hundred books life
could be better I guess life could be
worse too
I'm playing a bigger player
by a London
nice really okay we have this perk
variation usually happy to play this
we 903 preventing me five
is a very idea based opening
now he plays these five play Bishop g5
great oh he's gonna go for c5 that's
annoying
I'm kind of losing material I lose this
pawn
maybe I attack d6
a long-term weakness
I don't mind this position
upon but he doesn't have too much active
play
question is how am I going to actually
make progress in this position I want to
play for a win maybe H 5 at some point
who he plays g5
maybe I'll bring the King to f1 if he
lets me
okay he's trying for a draw because I'm
so bad I have to play throw-in
I quit the King on f1 and then put the
bishop on c2 maybe I'll hang is F fun
as f-fun
going on here oh that's meat I didn't
mean to meet him but I guess that was an
accidental checkmate
okay I'm in 44th place gonna try and go
streak again it's not easy to get a
streak every game is just off opponents
now I'm playing pigeons I know I've
played before I've played many times
before we're tied 20 and a half 20 and a
half
he's trying dirty stuff I've actually
studied this line though and he can't
take my queen and then maybe Queen a5
pretty sure this is on a refutation
ah maybe this and we can trade
everything
mmm booty sixes week
ie five as we suspicious not defended he
plays f4 okay he just hung upon I keep
attacking him
d5 coming my stuff play tempo moves
initiative is so important in bullets
whoo okay let's put the Queen on g6 and
plate b6
you
hmm I don't want to play h5 let's put
the nail on f8
maybe f6 at some points
and then e 5 ok good position let's put
the bishop on it's what the rook here
and then Bishop goes to f7
in the time advantage
yeah we can
oh I just hung my queen wait what the
game was going so well that I hung my
queen
I still have chances though my position
is so good
that's so unfortunate
take
and take care
I have counterplay
you
no I'm losing Paul I was so bad I was
crushing him too
I just like my queen
sixty-fifth place
is rough
who's leading penguins leading where is
doctor drunken Steen hey I'm playing
John Bartholomew uh what's confusing
with opening I'm gonna play some some
Petrov abbiamo Caruana style I'm so
scared this
all respect to JB he's my hero on the
play 97 and at some line he's doing the
same thing
um six
coming
3/6
I've realized this when he streams he's
slow but when I'm stream I'm also slow
oh it's gonna be a race
slower
or who's less slow I should say
9:05
I mean let's just make things
complicated
oh he's not streaming this
because he has a partnership with with
chess com I forgot about that but this
will be on YouTube later on his channel
interesting
off to beat him still
what's archived
yeah that wasn't the best decision but I
just want to [ __ ] him
let's play this move nice growth and
everything he's invading
checking account replay I guess I get
counterplay while I win the beep on
humans might be pong Oh in his H pawn
maybe
this is not easy it's going to be very
very close
back home
when up three
I come again I come again back I just
want to flag him
fork his Bishop hey this is going to be
really close I'm going to keep checking
him
please flag please flag oh he's he was
almost meeting me too
but he's too slow
he's strong this useless
okay 50th place pigeons I'm to get
revenge and he's he's berserk I'm not
gonna desert back because I need to get
revenge
this is my pet line such a nice line
ekta t45
the f4 to
nine of three okay
want to play e5
I was happening bring that night to see
five if he lets me
you
octi for who this is such a nice setup
such a good night but a bad dish if the
things as is
positional
masterpiece
Oh nonot rook f5
oh my gosh okay I'm still thinking on
win this but he's fast as we saw
previous game
hmm
wait I was getting a bit too cocky there
maybe he'll prima burgage too
you saw it
wait is young weird
he still made me
hey it still mates okay I don't feel so
bad I do feel bad cuz he deserts me I
messed that up after having such a great
positional game I guess I mouse slipped
to Rick at 5:00 Mike Carlson's and for
the first place that's not good
and playing mermen play an alkyne
let's play this and I don't know what
he's doing he's playing some of my Kings
in
you for the cheer Nathan for 20 bits
really appreciate the support
I will pay for maybe 15 minutes of
parking
okay I'm going for this typical
expansion
I don't mind the position nights are
better than bishops in these close
positions maybe I'll play g5 at some
points
ah his mates going to be good
yeah this is slightly annoying
you
efore was probably not necessary this
targeting b3
the pieces a little bit
Bishop any southern
at some point I might sack have to find
the right time
on the right square
I'm looking for squares to sacrifice on
wait what was that move
oh he tried to like he dirty and like
hope that eye cream move
that backfired
and I hear and then the other night here
everything's defended bring the King in
to be 98
upon
the king oh he's not gonna walk the King
oh he's gonna win the a pong ouch
what his bishops kind of trapped though
you
bugging him okay that was a good win
60th place have some catching up to do
I'm about to very 2500
a 60-second place
my best and
in London
sign
yeah I kind of like this line seems like
he might know theory though
well my night be three
going for positional play
can take a 95 bending 97
this castle
ooh
solid positional play is he trapping my
queen
or is off limits and I'm attacking his
night he might play nicéphore anyway I
would probably take and then play Knight
c5
hmm
be solid move
ooh yes he for now but
things are under control east six hung
nice
he's moving quickly
I'm also moving quickly
does that move interesting move
efore
a three hangs
I'm so indecisive is not a good quality
for bullets
wait I'm I'm low on time okay gotta move
much quicker
you
learn to channel my inner Andrew ting
yes okay
everyone has their inner and rooting
after challenger channel it's the right
way
okay I'm playing fonda 2600
play the slime
it's a slightly passive line but at
least I know what I'm doing kind of page
six who he wants to meet me that was
dirty
as close the rock on d5 and then double
up
before Intermezzo maybe a four
Ches that's a fork that's a triple of
work
rook t3 coming ooh efore was hanging -
this guy's falling apart and he's 2600 I
was a 2600 play like this let's not
ponder anything
that's a good move any more stuff so
many things are hanging take this
okay back to tournament do I have a
streak I have a streak and I have more
bits from Nathan f 30 bits another
half-hour of parking
I'm in 33rd place I'm playing rec cool
let's play it Manos
mmm he's playing the signs play uh play
this early e5 will move to no another
donation one dollar from Motoman
thank you
what does that move okay I guess I can
yeah indecisiveness again pick there and
put the bishop on g5 now he can't gather
up to see one unless he can
yeah maybe he'll play Roxy one that's
annoying
mmm fix
to do the same thing to him
lay here and maybe p5
I don't know what to do is playing well
okay now I can do this
it's still scary but I can play h6 at
some point maybe Bishop III yeah and
this
Bobby to pawn the a3 pawn plate we need
for next I'm expecting okay one
or that
five
to a weird position
a file
maybe my queen can infiltrate these
yes
mmm I'd get anything
get the ape on them
let's defend a long time
this is really scary do I do
maybe this move
- this is bad
really bad
and it except the D 2 square is B
meaning
[Music]
he flagged me you played ball that game
I thought I was playing decently you
just played better
where is carlson doctor drunken Steen
where are you in 25th he's not having a
good tournament
penguin has 38 it's still very early how
many things can change in a period of
time
okay weird opening
we're talking
that will play c4
one of our Kings will be slightly
suspicious they repeat one I guess
with the trail of Nitra bishop
Bishop c4
trapping the Queen b7 hangs
mmm so t3 solid move
tick and then King f1
on an attack of seven
my name or attack t6i chief to be I just
want to remove his queen
oh and I g3 was a decent move I think
maybe not I don't know
ah Queen to hear next
I don't know what's going on I just got
to play quick
does that move
you
that's really annoying
can take another five
finding some useful moves
I just want to push my F pawn to e4 okay
how's it bad pre move by him
this
you
on my endgame technique
no I drew the snow
oh my gosh
oh I don't my endgame technique
you
upper for work at 20 of time - I just
lost my composure
22 points
that's really sad I'm Valentin
and I I'll sit I kind took lady 4 will
play Kings Indian some kind of like
close Sicilian type line
laughs for
between D to Bishop h6 he's usually a
good trade
maybe there will be weaknesses that pop
up
there's 95 IOT for
I don't know where he's gonna put his
Knights doesn't seem that great maybe
this move wait
where's my kill
looks good enough
and d5
you
[Music]
I'm going crazy
feeling about this
you
or bits 120 bits
you wait I'll look in the chat in a
moment
I still have hope here though I put the
pawn on c4
or if I trade and then put the pawn on
c4 he's going to play c6
on my sneaky attack
so sad a good position to
wait a minute am i winning this I'm
winning this how did that happen
no no okay
so I promoted a pawn but then I realized
I didn't want to throw the pawn and I
didn't realize after you promote the
pawn you can undo the promotion that's
good to know
oh that was close Nathan F just subbed
for three months in a row and Thank You
gray Heather for the 120 bits I do
appreciate that I'm playing bazoo by my
a sneaky sideline
maybe okay he doesn't know it
play Bishop for
be restricting the notes it's a decent
move
back
of equal
trade
is very equal
more
[Music]
mind oh my gosh I just lost a brook
bloody embarrassing
as I was about to say I don't mind equal
positions I do mind getting destroyed
like that
okay stay focus
my bishops not supposed to be four in
that line
okay fine we focus
not the most pleasant position actually
because I might be losing upon but maybe
not
the see ponds weak
it's a tricky move maybe Queen a5 looks
ugly
I want to win his pawn
still want to win this pawn
taketake doesn't work
time deficits at the best
you
oh it's fun singing
I want to pawn
the king
it's kind of annoying
Brookes gonna come maybe not but he's
threatening mate market needed
and we can trade
be up upon
oh my gosh she won that piece and I'm
low in time but my pawn is maybe
promoting my pawns promoting that
happened he just resigns that was kind
of unexpected
I did not intend that I'll take it in
44th for the first place wizard 98 good
luck
okay I usually like these positions with
the open H file pretty early
a completely for
becomes 495
ooh he's asking for it
he's really asking for it
figure out how to Russian though
maybe this move first
that hurts I didn't see that coming
that was just a pawn though okay about
the end of the world my nights kind of
hanging play this move I want to do that
what's going on here
like a very bad position oh you've made
smiie on one move
the undeserving bits
like a frog Oh 47
intend to play King's Indian but now I'm
playing at Kings Indian yet I fortune I
should play the Kings Indian more often
if this is actually what happens
now go for Bishop f5 and then Knight e4
I'm just up a piece
a lot of this tournament is just
maintaining composure and you get good
positions and you have to convert them
Queen b6 what does queen oh he meant to
play queen take b7 I guess
look I have 28 points leader has 60
points Carlson is not in the top 10 he's
in 14th place okay I'm only 14 points
behind Carlson after 40 minutes of play
that's not too bad I guess
okay we have some or London action let's
play 92 first
there should be five line again weenie
southerners I think one of the main
lines
but this can't be good I don't think on
this end and attacked twice might be
three happens
Oh his queen was defended I forgot about
that maybe it's okay for black
I still like my position
all right get some time edge if possible
move
good news
we'll have my c5 square
side-on storm a valid plundering that
was a blunder
what is he doing is being so weird
I want to play night teeth oh that's
good move
play this move
my rookie three
buying some good moves but I like my
position I'm winning upon I'll be up
upon
many ponds
you
okay this should be an easy win
you
it's going to keep pushing
you
I'm just going for the flag
okay that was close
I did converts I'm on a streak I have 30
points
hey I broke 2,500 I didn't even realize
it
25 30 now playing kick kick ETF
know what opening this is a strange
opening
se5
we can trade tick with queen
trade more stuff
c64 the 997
[Music]
it's
five looks nice
the defy ball this nice kind of stuck
as bishop stuck
I have two pieces for the rook
maybe this and then B for ideas
these week is play at four
go for this trade I just want to remove
the pond from f3 so I can play 94 and
then f5 watch a nice setup
there we go
you
yeah because everything defends
everything
and hmm I have many ideas
uh what to do let's go after that pawn
[Music]
[Music]
you
Vicki mover k-6
a lot of time now
you
I just want to meet him
hmm
Oh b6 is almost meat
oh my gosh he's doing some dirty
tell me tricks
sex mates yes okay
good thing I realized still many
possibilities that was very sneaky
penguin GM is you know he's in second
place I'm scared now
okay I'm to take care of business baby
if he knows his London lines please
start thinking okay he doesn't know his
London lines
oh we had this before he doesn't know
his London lines okay we'll see what
happens maybe I for Oh F for hyung III
but he didn't see it moving too quickly
go penguin thank you for the bits
whoever you are
[Music]
the shop on e3 oh that was a good move
I'm okay sacking exchange is ee6 is weak
and we'll go for some play
always flicking each one
I forgot the thing was hanging I didn't
mean to play b6 either oh what a bad
game but I have accidental compensation
what is going on here you might be in
trouble because his rook is hanging and
I be pawn is dangerous I have this move
coming Queen C ones check is going to
happen then King g2 I have no idea
what's going on it's kind of turned
around in weird ways
maybe the smooth
and then this move I have initiative
wing g6 coming am I gonna win this I
don't deserve to win this but I might
actually win this
mean d6 he's too slow with this pawn oh
no I didn't see that move though
oh no okay Oh No
I have to push past pawns oh that's so
sad
are what moved in I see Brooke take
eight
I should just take in Queen a eights
easy win
oh that's so disappointing well I played
penguin now I have to play Carlson
I mean okay I didn't deserve to him I
played most of that game
got a bit careless when he was winning
I'm playing some more smurfed 42 another
London
that's a dirty Claire Bishop c4
thankfully I'm not I'm slow enough to
realize Bishop g4 so free pawn rights
and trade queens now
that's a free night kind of sort of
let's take here first but I'll win the
night oh that was a good move and see
that
ah
assumed he was a weak player
okay
I've worked to do
you
I'm gonna try and bring a night to eat
both
possible
we go
through this
my tea for maybe Oh sneaky move
this oh he takes on e5 you're all about
that
get play on the kingside not going to
happen though ah so bad
please play rugby - no oh maybe
stalemate possibilities no okay
that was unfortunate game against
penguin
I said
okay 34 points
I have half the number of points as a
leader Carlson's in second 20 points
behind romanian force I'm going to
Romania in next month
or weeks maybe
put my flight's okay we have a cool line
- time
you
upon such a weird position
ooh maybe I should have taken on g4 I
still can
what does this take take
I guess I have to take
and we trade Queens some weird position
all in the c7 pawn I better win the c7
pawn good move
you
maybe I can trap this rook
mmm this is annoying
oh that's very annoying
I have to get lucky please hang mates
lose hang mates No
[Music]
you
okay
you
hinge
you
you
you
you
yes I flagged him undeserving but I
flagged him it's a draw
how I'm going to score points
tournaments
still over 2,500 he had many Mason 1xi
towards end there I'm playing lar so
other streamer who oddly is not
streaming right now
kind of like Tori setup
um weights position looks good
goodnight
this is kind of ugly let's
trade off into some and gain on when I'm
up a bishop I don't think he intended
that
you
oh my gosh am I losing this
a commission
I said
humans other bishop too
very close to resign
let's resign that's really sad what a
disappointment
well I'm still top 50
very far away from the money mean to
pull some kind of Street together
ever London it starts
kind of touch setup Castle queenside oh
he had a - that would have been very
very bad
act upon I'm sacking more pawns I just
want open files to attack on
this
it each one's half open
I've interesting move
you
want to get rid of the bishop mmm what
do I do
I guess I just attack
hopefully before he can
of his own attack
you
I'll play d5 and rotate g6 somehow but
not going to work
you
the pawn counts ons are about equal
you
yes I can take
and before
it's easier to play with the Queen in
these sort of positions but maybe not
we'll see okay you loud to five it's
nice
we know six is coming
this is very nice
you
one second left
job done okay hopefully that's the start
of something good see
because Gio
the Strunk gonna try and keep
composure based some normal chess
theoretical line happening
I will admit I don't know too much
theory here the p7
this is equal material
night which is
you
at this idea happening f3 is always a
good move for whites
this
you
and trade queens
not the easiest position to play
trying to attack as pawn somehow
a three that's a free pond
maybe he meant to play a four
I'll be threes week
you
a follow
in a while since a follow happened Thank
You P Jax
oh he wants to make me put this and then
run away
please don't maybe
there's needs
even more he's gonna play h6 at some
point when I played g6 such a confusing
position maybe I can made him somehow
hey I'm meeting him
okay that was nice I won two in a row
two I was keen crusher
I hadn't me maybe I'll play him next his
forty points I have 39 points grey
Hatter with a hundred bits appreciate
the bits
okay um playing Rain Man
let's try and still take this seriously
- three
see five I think I can take
and maybe e5
mm I have no idea what's going on now
looks decent though
central control
maybe he'll play Bishop f5
happening
is going to wind up with the bishop here
take take
maybe I lose upon
upon here but now the positions quieter
you
do this and this animus
[Music]
don't want to allow him any passed pawns
be I'll bring the King t4 push pawns
more
when the king to g4 how about
this is scary it's also scary for him
because I'm threatening mate and then
King f5 I'm still training me he has to
sack is Bishop but then I wind
he just resigns that was a nice game
activity is more important than material
very important lesson in bullets ok play
some chess here almost for the classic
b5 trick
three in a row
five
rating blacks up upon
the pieces on reasonable squares
mmm it moves go back
maybe a six
it's annoying position still up upon but
not anymore
oh let's trade off he has a time
advantage
I wanted
you
ah this is not what I wanted
oh I was really unfortunate a top 40
whereas Carlson
Roslin's number five
my money is still on Carlson
even if you lost a ting
don't mate okay let's have a b3 line
F for I think I've seen that for before
I'm placing normal moves
let's do this
back
twenty-seven
hmm I hung up on
the Hyun of Han
just a trailer puns
interesting
that was tricky
very good move losing the exchange
RUP t5 comes
I was stronger
I'm holding on
interesting let's hold on even more
the pawn on each three put the King on
b6 and then when the e4 pawn except nots
hmm
is annoying I'll put the Bishop on e4
Havanese just gonna take my name for him
you
this is so sad
I can meet him meeting attack
his work
these work
Oh
you
No okay uh sad
I still want to play Carlson but it's
not looking likely giving given my place
in the tournament
well who knows I just need a streak I've
had one too I feel like there's a
pattern with my performance
like 2 to 4 to 2 for 2 to 4 so I haven't
won more than three games in a row
another sad thought play more
aggressively okay just for great Heather
I'm gonna be super aggressive this game
going for h4 h5
I play super aggressive a night b5 every
move should be a threats of c3 which
nice position limit of e 5 what is that
a super aggressive chess ship t3
happening
Aion is to completely destroy the sky
yeah 95 happening also 96 ideas
lots of arrows everywhere as I made
threats oh did I hang a piece a pieces
don't matter all that matters is
checkmate
I'm just doing this for grey Hatter if I
lose this game I'm blaming him I'm
sacking pieces everywhere this better be
made on each seven oh he took the pawn
or the night
okay I still have an attack except I
have no almost no pieces to attack with
oh let's do this in this
and maybe Hertz okay
I still have Queens
I'm gonna have to flag him I'm down to
pieces in a rook
after this turn so badly
yes I did sacrifice everything
No
stop it oh man
great how der is T for that game I had a
good position though I just got way too
back reficul with my piece
okay playing some guy
hey more bits this is what happens yeah
gray Hatter is 1100 they've told me that
beforehand
okay we have some benoni which I want to
take that punk is Queen a for check
though it's going to develop stuff I've
looks
maybe pre-move more than normal
ninety-seven
seven prevents h3 one some lines I'll
have to keep this defended
ooh I dropped a bishop
it's bad but rookie eight happens this
might be good
I'm still trying to play aggressively
some attack
where's my attack don't see my attack
B I have to slow play like this in this
[Music]
situations really really bad my peace
situation even worse
oh he took my queen
I'm on tilt I should I should be calm
someone should tell me to play
positional chess
positional chess is a way to go
okay I'm playing little little pumpkin
wonder if it's a relative of little
Plotkin
positional chess here we come
you
I still have this urge to play
aggressively we have the start position
now going after this pawn or bits from X
I sparks complete positional chess
okay it's hard to play positional chess
when you have a position or there's ops
aside castling and I'm losing a piece
because i blundered i have to i have to
play super sharp here just hunt pawns
nothing but pawns I'm attacking upon
you
badly
or really greatly depending on whether
or not I can meet him I might be meeting
him I just have to gather rook to H AIDS
bishop here and then rotates the threats
he's don't make me uh he won my bishop
okay still not over
to do this
just about over
running out of pieces
everything hoping its mate and then it's
not mate I'm just down material
and I'm flagging too
I think this is my worst losing streak
so far
oh my gosh okay
these are some comforts
it's but I'm trying not to give up but I
just lost one two three four lost five
games in a row I'm still top hundred
butts
not a great performance monkey king okay
let's change up the opening let's play
in English
one of the more positional openings yes
okay some symmetrical English you can
live with this lady for
you start positions again
I don't know why I can't escape the
short positions
actually this could calm down I could
trade everything it'll calm down into
some to Bishop advantage
and then d5 okay that's a good sign
a very good sign
oh my gosh I I think this is okay though
Queen c2 c7
are these moves
three tick
to calculate the complications but it's
difficult I play this move because it's
so complicated Queen h6 King G - he
takes my queen
I have c7
I take and then take the rook
I have two rooks and or a bishop and a
rook for the Queen I have a pawn in b7
rook d7 happens and then a four
I guess
let's play rugby one turning this
it's down on time now
[Music]
Oh complicated he just hung whoo he
didn't hang the rook
I need a miracle
please do something
[Music]
and routing again
you
and routing activates
No
you
oh my gosh it's a draw yes I was
incredible
hello every games gonna go aaaghh well
it at least it's like less than an hour
left
seventy first place well I lost our I
ended the losing streak which is good
and now I'm playing weaker players
of more bits from exei sparks thank you
and gray Hatter appreciate all the love
I'm gonna play the Ray Robson variation
it's actually a fun line against this
opening
prep b5 is prep rook b8 will be prepped
at a p2 will be prepped how much crap
this is prep bell rookie sevens prep hey
another dollar from Manhattan a humid -
man so generous
it's annoying move let's play this
ideas of
ideas of 95 I have to play this I'm sad
my pieces are now in bad squares
IG five is scary I have 9f 558
what is he doing
my guys a
position
you
I'm so confused about this position
I'm just trying to find harmony with the
pieces before it looks like a nice
square for the night but now I don't
have that night
I have to get my other Knight to g4
oh my gosh what does rooks III what is
Bishop before
was a really bad sequence of moves for
both of us
this is a benefit of playing weaker
players
this
oh my gosh
I have to flag him
Oh
I flagged him when he had like Nathan
won every move in a row like what is
this starting with this move made in one
maven one maven one
may than one
and again made in one in like five or
six maiden ones there
at least I won a game it's been a while
since I won a game 46 points 64th place
from the channel my inner crew 64 baby 3
know if this is positional chess maybe
it is positional chess I'm a hippo like
I don't mind this before and then I Chi
3 & 9 f5
and keep things controlled Castle
queenside go for f4 take this I guess
each six is hanging
have taken that the previous move
over f4 very soon
hmm BC for
this is a little bit unpleasant this
pieces are better than mine by 95 maybe
I still want to play 95 at some points
hmm it will now g6 a week
five is weak
each five is weak
we see seven ideas
want to trade Queens
I'm going to be a time scramble I have
to trade Queens
you
no not good
I still make myself you still made me
queen bee seven
they'll make me
you
they'll mate
okay
I was unfortunate
forty-two minutes left let's try and
break top fifty and let's try and break
twenty five hundred again 140 bits
rush them all believe okay I'm trying to
believe we have a four pawns attack
don't see this every day
maybe not the best response
I'm Hardy down upon this is a fork maybe
Bishop here coming
let's move the night back
the rook let's not okay rook d3 was a
risky pre move
debate more stuff
X positional
I'd see - that's a fork
gonna play Rupp t1 ooh and see that move
have this move stuff is still hanging
stuff is still hanging and he's so
tricky
how he escaped that
mmm five open things up
hmm
you
oh he wants to meet me in one it's not
pleasant
okay we can trade oh no I'm losing the
bishop in the end and take care oh that
was even worse
I made him with just an ITIN the bishop
probably not
you
not resigning because I'm frustrated
and also he might flag
you
these flag you took my pond
he flagged okay
I've had way too many games like that
are you accepting after this arena um
I'll see how I feel probably not this is
a lot of chess the last time I played
this titled arena was several months ago
I've missed a lot of them because I've
had conflicts the last time I play that
was in Singapore it was like 5 a.m. I
was at the airport I was playing from
one of that like airport computers it
was an interesting experience
I'm gonna try and get back on the streak
I mean my my prep again
just a fun line to play
let's try and like win the game without
flagging the opponent I don't know if
that's going to be possible
I'll see
hmm
of not allowed bishop takeoff three
palm
back to spawn
maybe I'll just push the upon two
either thumbs push the C pawn
going to try and meet me
thought like rookie six and queen h5
ideas would be dangerous but now it's
okay
the King ruck f2 wreckage to
this
mmm I didn't see that pawn is hanging
I'm still defending and if
now I'm definitely defending upon tyne
good stuff
my hand is falling asleep stop falling
asleep
you
interesting okay I'm dirty flagging him
sorry guy
my hand is still asleep
it's the way I'm holding the mouse what
did you do in Singapore I spent a lot of
time at the Singapore Airport I flew
through Singapore I think three times
during my last trip through through
Southeast Asia
I had like a 19-hour way over or
something but it's such a nice Airport
like it's the nicest Airport in the
world didn't run out of things to do
but then I visited some friends I went
to like the Marina Bay took a lot of
pictures was a fun trip
it's kind of scary position but Brian
cope with it
should be seven
when I get
I played 93
[Music]
do this first
make sure I don't get needed
you
this is not going to end well or maybe
it will not getting mated here
a five gray move we'll trade stuff
yes
wants to meet me take this what a great
center
yeah he's playing my style he's
attacking everything hoping it's meat
but it's not going to be mates call him
up I'm up to pieces
in g8
him
you
interesting move
he's gonna win my queen but won't be
enough
Brook
playing chess is tiring
oh he hung more or I hung more stuff
still winning this
ohmygosh theory
okay that was too close for comfort
hey I'm on a streak again I wrote 50
points I'm about to break 2500
um way out of the money while Carlson is
behind Carlson needs to wrap it up
playing ripka 89 area plays Sicilian oh
my gosh why did I play c4
another Nassif
it seems fast
upon buying forking two pawns in the
play might be three
ooh tricky move as to trade
ooh I win the pawn back
you
hmm
you
I don't want to play a five-foot
defendi for
reinforce it bishop
either smooth
very tricky
not sure what's going on here
to hold everything together
this king is also unsafe spycheck
I think he makes me
it's scary though
my hiding place he lets me
here's my hiding place
there we go
okay one a game oh that's three in a row
running a new street
now Jess thanks for watching
65th place 55 points
I broke 2500 yet again
ADRC
streaking it I'll allow that let's do
this
95 typical time on earth
maybe h5 isn't so typical but it's
playable
this guy's playing creatively
I'm trying to play creatively too
do this
bg5 happening
a g5 coming
I'll still play g5
tricky move
now the G files open
that's a good thing or a bad thing
in a smooth 87
that's kind of painful I have to sack
liquid Bishop ng8 ooh what is that
he's crushing me but maybe I survived
you
know what's going on in this position
you should maybe getting mated somehow
or maybe I'm getting mated out I'm
getting mated
not good
you
ah so sad
back to tournaments
I was on a streak too I still need to
win four games in a row
okay final London
mmm good for this line
I don't care about pawns
this
five
goodnight see 3 there
I'm winning something because I have
before coming up
as week
you
hmm
you
it's tough
I've reached the point where it's it's
difficult to talk and play good chess
or just play good chess
trying to mess up
quickly
Knight to G me
you
that's a dirty trick I have to flag him
now
everything's defended
kind of
still want to bring my night to g5
you
okay dirty game but I won back over 2500
again
I did I give him be - it was uh gambits
I mean it takes so much time to take B -
I was developing pieces in the meantime
I think it worked out well too
using bullets you care more about its
activity rather than anything else
and I'm going to be aggressive this game
you can't take the night's dangerous
question is how do I make progress with
it back
in 94 at some points
me too
sting g4 might be a good move he can't
take the bishop because I have made into
a
as exciting
okay 65th place two in a row 59 points
26 minutes left their vana
Raymond doesn't like gambits I'm sorry
about that
this will most likely not be a gambit
London opening
can take that
that was a bad move
confused with the move order
- position
have a bad bishop
more kini to Brooke to see one
Pelagius day five
right back
you don't know what to do here leave
this move he's gonna play Knight g4
though or not
it let's put the rook on f1 and then
bring the Knight to c3 attacking d5 and
pressuring b5
it's not really doing anything
he's storming
can take that
bb3 at some points
almost trapping the rook
I really now I want to play f3
or not
this pawn is kind of weak
you
I'm up on time a lot of time
have active rook
ha and he didn't see it though
you
[Music]
okay oh that's two in a row
oh that's three in a row nice 63 points
trying to break into top 50
let's first place looking like our Olsen
not in top ten
happened to Carlson
that's not good
what place is Carlson
you
I like my position
night back to g6 maybe 9 f7
mmm
you
I like the smooth
actually I don't know how much I liked
it I didn't see that oh that's
unfortunate maybe I'll win f5 I'll just
be down upon
he's holding on
wait I'm down a piece I'll lose a piece
not down a piece what am I saying it's
when a six
it's a I t5o he wins upon
a bishop
chips are good
you
miss Bishop isn't so good
you
oh this is really unfortunate
you
hmm
you
the lion thing on he's not gonna
stalemate me
again
ah tough game
tough I think I've fully adapted to my
mouse so I'm not feeling too many many
issues with it
Oh Carlson is playing Andrew currently a
Carlson's in eighth place 15 points
behind
I don't know why I played Knight c3
this has like a weird London
h5 is not necessary
no idea what this opening is but I think
you've lost upon
another free pawn
free pond
coupons like Christmas
even celebrate Christmas okay I'm in the
castle and beat up three pawns
tricky Oh
Oh
weights let's know I'm losing more pawns
dude I lost a rook too
this is bad
maybe I can like pull a nigel Schwartz
yeah that's my only hope
shorts
oh he sees my plan I can take that pawn
ah wait ecigs what's his plan
jiwan's his plan
as a confusing position
you
hey I'm winning that was weird
well I'm tired but other people are
tired too so hey I'm playing King
crusher let's destroy him
F for what is f for
in strange
paid queens oh he's just playing quickly
okay it's not playing great moves
hmm I can castle
the bishop
I've
or
paid more
bit more
ooh that's so tricky of him was really
tricky with him
I was also very tricky at him I thought
I was up more material but I guess I'm
just up to pawns but still a lot of Hans
hmm let's do this
[Music]
he's being resourceful also I'm really
low on time
but the bishop on e4 he's gonna win more
pawns no
you
when b3 don't make me
what made me
okay this is looking better
looking much better check him
you
ah okay King crusher that wasn't so easy
I thought it was gonna be easy but
wasn't so easy okay fifty second place I
still want to win four games in a row
I've won two two in a row
um just two more
okay
you
to keep in mind everyone's tired I have
to keep my composure
but my pieces on good squares
double the rooks on the C file
proving
him to do something
[Music]
he's doing something I don't think
that's too impressive though this is
weak how this stuff is weak
maybe it's justifiable though
mmm hey this is a crazy position
I don't know what's going on
it's better for me though
to bishops
I hide my king
just have to think either this bishop
avoid any perhaps still scary
let's play this move
Oh No Queen d5 I'll play Queen d5 don't
do it don't do it oh he didn't do it
okay now it should be winning
I'm gonna do something bad to him
if he lets me
he's hanging a rook
you
you
hmm
No
so sad Carlson's in ninth I don't know
what's more sad that game or the fact
that Carlson will not be winning this
and Andrew tang is about to win $3,000
for playing a few game for playing two
hours of bullets Wow
ten bits from Nathan I'm trying to hang
in there
but really the only thing I'm hanging is
my pieces
that makes sense
the Grand Prix
there's a rule whenever you play at four
always play king h1
okay good thing my queen was defended
or to attack when you don't have means
on the board
hmm
I'm the sack as Bishop h6 looks enticing
maybe not the most impressive thing ever
this is week I want to meet him next
move
if it only moves he's kind of stuck
I'll win his pawn
someday
rocket forks
position
meet him
you
six is about to be made please don't see
it I
if he can stop it though
this is just meat how does he defend
this
and if he takes the night and I have
made on d8 that was nice
wait what no later
okay
again Vava chess
I said earlier I put my money on Carlson
good thing I didn't put actual money on
Carl's
let's do this
is gonna be annoyingly symmetrical oh
can I take and then do maybe you do this
first
I saw queenside and attack
it's file
vicious
[Music]
let's play rogue age six just simple
double up
take all these pieces and then I'll meet
him and keep taking pieces
I didn't see that but I can take
maybe this
my queen has been hanging for too long
care about my queen
I care about the h-file
oh okay now I care about my queen
you
should be made somehow maybe not
I'm at least winning a rook
you
hey opposition
there's a mate okay this king is like a
cockroach trying to kill it doesn't die
I'm over 2,500 I wanted to break top 50
but well I'm close I guess
interesting move
you
each three
Ricki position the lot of things are
trading go be up upon
whoo he winds up on back
qinger fail in rocky eights
maybe go for h5
you
six in King g7
not sure what's going on here
you
upon
I'm winning the f2 pawn
okay I'm up upon we can trade rooks
would be a technical win
mmm still tricky
you
yeah what's going on here
you
mm-hmm
you
we trade queens okay
51st place I got two points for that
draw
pickle dick
us try not to lose
they'll open
hmm
the pretty equal variation
- good positional chess
developed and put the rooks in the
center
you
maybe a six
you
you can take my rook with this Bishop if
he wants
maybe fella wasn't the best idea
keep attacking him
[Music]
okay yeah that was definitely not the
best idea
still interesting though I have two
pieces for a queen
I win g2
this is not good oh this is really bad
back rank issues
yeah I'm just tired oh he hung my he
hung his queen I was about to resign but
never resign when you win a queen back
I'm up on time okay maybe I can flag him
storm
you
maybe I can check Nate him
you
with Chuck
eat me
bag
no he made it me
I was so close to winning this
ah
I just stop and watch
Carlson's not gonna win this 916 points
Allah Reza to win
I don't even know who that is
so after day
you
this might be my last game I'm getting
tired I don't really see the point of
finishing the tournament I just swung
upon oh man
nine of three cones
it's actually interesting I have
counterplay here
he5
my e5
it's definitely some counterplay
you
oh I didn't see Queens egg after
let's try and finish the tournament with
a win
I'm not gonna give up so easily I am
still about 2,500
Carlson is a past the future is spelled
Cara wanna yeah let's use a Carolina
emotes
okay let's beat the sky and then wrap it
up with ZD
[Music]
I've been streaming for a long time
because I started streaming like an hour
before the tournament started is to warm
up
you
hiring activity
I do appreciate people who are watching
this you had so many other choices of
people to watch including the world
champion so thank you to the loyal
viewers on he could have trapped my
queen
rook g5
he just wants to trade Queens
I like this position there's no no
worries in the world like Kim D - I'll
probably just do nothing until he flags
night a1 is a great night c1 nice
nothing nothing moves
maybe g5 something move
actually I move
downward is heavenward hundred bits
appreciate that our IP
yeah let's just trying to get this
let's finish this off in style
looking for me
you
there's made here
King I need to bring the knight in
you know I have some perpetual
be now that five now I'm threatening me
there we go
okay
there is time for a game I'm tired and
end it there I'm not gonna end the
stream I'm just gonna end a tournament
pause go back to the tournament I am in
60th place
um let's play one more game
top 50 I'm in the buzzer the next game
no matter what if it starts police
starts
or the game
you
it's not gonna start oh it started let's
booze Erick okay
please bezerk back yes okay at one more
game in
that was a weird decision be five move
oh my gosh
you
hey I'm up a piece
as bishop
it's tough
big more stuff
or stuff
I'm up a night for two ponds
and tricky move Knight f6
raining
you
[Music]
you
I have no idea what's going on here
you
yes oh no I know
and I think the tournament ended before
that game counted if I'm not mistaken
yeah okay wait Angwin gia and won the
tournament
Wow congratulations and routing $3,000
Carlsen not in the top five
or was he in the top five he finished
seven out
you
a rough event
Karlsson started the tournament over
3,000
and he ended below 2,900
yeah I'm gonna end it there before I go
thank you to everyone who followed and
subscribed donated I'll be back for more
instructive streams this has been a very
busy very very busy last several weeks I
was out of town
I was streaming pretty consistently
before I left town but then I got that
just a few days ago so I'm working to
put together a more or consistent
schedule um before I go
Thank you Thank You followers donators
too many people to mention but I do
appreciate the love and and yeah I will
be back
um let's raid someone my raid let's raid
the counts
um please don't end your stream these
you don't know I might be having a match
against account very soon
don't know what he's doing
Oh
okay we're gonna raid him when he's not
not looking
or maybe we'll wait until he gets back
and then we're gonna raid him
I've ten minutes
no I want to raid him wait don't go
I want to raid you
okay we're gonna raid him anyway why
didn't I win the whole thing because I
tried my best
a success people played better chess in
me but it was fun when you raid in five
minutes okay well raid in five minutes
Siri set the timer for five minutes
for five minutes
okay
people can see this
that is five minutes okay so in the
meantime I will answer questions I'll
interact with people I'll do whatever
you guys want me to do with the
exception of giving a Simon or playing
classical chess
there's a monthly classical arena going
on right now
serious Wow
um interesting
friends online
um
[Music]
umm Carlson lots of sites a date for
Carlson
they come for a little bit go back
all the people still streaming
shots bathing many times before in
person
Oh Lila is down yeah I would play Lila
chess man from Utrecht thanks for the
follow
yeah I really don't know what to do I
don't want to play more chess I'll
answer questions I will give advice I
guess I could play games with people if
anyone wants to challenge me like one
quick game
this feels like chess overload though
yeah definitely no more bullets yeah
send me a challenge maile chest name is
in the chat
or no maile chest name is just my full
name oh oh sub ham is challenging me
guys want to play one minute okay
was gonna accept sub ham but I guess I'm
accepting her Vaughn Raymond who I think
was watching the full streams I might as
well give him a game he knows my
openings but he doesn't know g4
aggressively
rushing to play nine title players
is a bigger holes to exploit
as an f6
uh how do I get a night to FC oh that's
how
my guess
weaknesses
inside I went to Castle queenside I even
said Castle queenside
but
okay and still up a queen
for Bishop d3
pick
for
you one will come very soon
[Music]
pick on maybe I'll make a new queen
or just made him md7 okay
we just lacks voice coupled commands
that would be really cool s had place
for people who don't have any hands
okay um someone else wanted to challenge
their ekeus farm okay we're gonna play a
sub ham
with already
you
I'm tempted to play London but we'll
play some classical ready
hello I'm singer bill here I'm singer
how is your flights
where where did you fly to the arena was
crazy
Olson did not even play stop five
and I didn't even play stop 50
as a sad day for everyone
was fun
we'll be a lot of replays to watch
I need that on Sunday
aiight uh my g5 doesn't quite work
like Queen c2 first
penguin was another great day full
respect to penguin
I might winning women in winning $3,000
that alarm means it's time to raid
account give it until the end of the
scheme
rushing the night around
am i moving so slowly with a quicker
maybe I'll made him some
dark square
now the interesting move
being resourceful I got to move much
quicker
this is a bad position
this is really bad I'm losing good thing
this is casual
you
you
you
you
hey I flagged him uh-huh
I was dirty my grams is great Jules
you'll z18 yeah I'm going to end off
everyone to uh my gosh wait what
I still have this pending challenge to
magnus carlsen he's no longer online
let's close some tabs those close go
back to account stream
hopefully he's back but I can read him
please be back I'm already typing it in
braids Jess Allah
I'm ending it there thanks guys for
watching I'll be back at some point
maybe tomorrow maybe sometime this
weekend hopefully okay bye